[Music]
teen moms farrah abraham was arrested
for allegedly slapping a security guard
now she's speaking out about the
incident so some information is wrong
out there according to police records
obtained by e.t
abraham was placed on a citizen's arrest
over the weekend and later booked on a
charge of misdemeanor assault by the
lapd she was released from custody less
than two hours later e.t has reached out
to abraham's reps for comment
abraham took to instagram sunday night
to address the incident she shared this
video of her arrest outside of the
restaurant grand master recorders in
hollywood where the incident allegedly
transpired
in the caption she called the incident
quote a conspired attack
abraham explained quote i post this as
no woman or man should ever be battered
abused conspired ganged upon set up
recorded and video sold
abraham recently enrolled in harvard
extension school to pursue a law degree
and she added quote i look forward to my
law degree and i look forward to court
justice will be served as always
abraham's court date is slated for may
19th
and the reality star shared more alleged
details to her instagram story
this message reads quote i was attacked
on the rooftop and tried to leave for
safety and was then assaulted by a
security guard abraham also shared this
photo seemingly showing injuries she
sustained
abraham tagged the restaurant on the
image and wrote
damaging my body is serious and legal
protocols were not followed on a public
sidewalk awaiting police
this is against the law charges will be
in full effect as no one should ever
have this happen to them stop
normalizing abuse
[Music]
and the incident comes just days after
abraham's return to reality tv
and you never know who will show up in
teen mom family reunion she reunited
with some of her original co-stars
hi good to see you
invited pharah one of those ogs was
amber portwood who opened up to e.t
earlier this month about abraham's
return
you know that fans are so eager to tune
in to really see what the dynamic is
going to be like watching pharah with
you ladies reunited again you know how
explosive did things really get you know
a lot of people said this so far like
everybody should be there
everybody had the right to be there and
farah had the right to be there because
she was a part of the original og's no
matter what you know i think you guys
will be really really like surprised you
know with how we did we kind of dealt
with a lot of the drama that they threw
at us